the gyro can experience one interesting
proof point of this is I think a poll
came out yesterday on where the American
people stand on impeachment and
something like 75 80 percent of Fox
viewers oppose impeachment and 75 80
percent of NBC MSNBC viewers support
impeachment and they're covering the
very same impeachment inquiry and
hearings and we know witness testimony
and all of that I don't think people
even understand what that all means and
whether or not it even has a chance of
happening you know base no I don't think
I don't think people do either they
don't they just it seems like some fun
talking point some gotcha thing where
they've got them
you know Ukraine taught him we got him
we got him this time stormy Daniels
didn't stick but this one this one's
gonna say yeah you know you think
yourself if stormy Daniels didn't stick
and just try and work with the guy at
that point I'm like okay you know what
he's he's Teflon we're just need to move
on and move forward there's a hilarious
girl I don't know who she is then I send
you that video with the girls getting
people to get pumped up about
impeachment and she's got like like
rainbow colored hair and she looks like
a liberal I think she even has one of
those pink kitty cat hats on and and she
gets them she's like Pro impeach they
like yeah impeach and [ __ ] a peach but
she goes yay president pence yeah yeah
she's like president pigs so if he gets
a peach then we get president pence and
then she's like maybe we should just
like let this play you know probably
just let him finish his term baby this
is it is hilarious it's hilarious
because P it's a sport it's it's it's
basically replacing its for it's a sport
for people don't like football it's like
their their idea of who's winning or
losing this game is very personal and
they feel like their team got killed in
2016 and they leave to come back and
kick ass in 2020 and that's what's going
on and everything they can get at them
well not not only that I mean that it's
it's that but then you've got some folks
who some some Democrat leaders and in
Washington who are saying well you know
we need to get rid of Trump through
impeachment
to protect ourselves from possibly
losing the election in 2020 which i
think is just like a an open and you
know admit all of well we don't think
that we can actually beat him at the
ballot box so we're trying to use this
political maneuver in order to get rid
of him even though it's it's highly
unlikely that even if the house does
vote to impeach which isn't fully clear
at this point but even if that were to
happen the Senate is not going to
convince at twenty it's highly unlikely
the Senate's going to convince twenty
Republicans to vote with every Democrat
to to actually physically kick Trump out
of office and that this is why I mean
I've always maintained that you know
look I look forward to beating Donald
Trump at the ballot box where the
American people can unequivocally let
their voices be heard saying nope we're
done with the leadership and and all
that Trump brought to office and we're
choosing to go in a new direction
have you thought about what kind of
nickname he'll have for you because you
know he's gonna come up with a nickname
yeah did you see how they they played
you on Saturday Night Live I did I was
there cuz I said I got to see what they
did to her and I was really curious
about what they were gonna do how they
were gonna make you out and he made you
out to be like this super evil person
yes I got a kick out of it no it's it's
a it's a it's a super short clip but
basically they're like there is a
villain amongst all of these candidates
and that villain is Tosi yeah he strikes
fear into the heart of every other
person up here I have something like
that like a despicable me type cartoon
villain they portrayed me as like a
Corolla Davila the thing is I was
thinking as it was playing out out they
don't show you for when I go they're not
even gonna put her in here I was like
they're not even they're not even gonna
put her in here they they you know
Clinton got to her and said oh I don't
want to be air time at all it's just
it's just so interesting to me that they
it's it's so clear that you're a vibrant
candidate but that they don't want to
get behind you yeah but yet they do want
to get behind Joe Biden who can barely
get through a sentence
that poor guy is falling but someone
needs to give that guy like growth
hormone steroids like kale shakes fat
steaks like bro you need to take some
time off we to get you in a hyperbaric
chamber you don't have any energy yeah
especially because Donald Trump has
entered yes and he goes on stage for an
hour and a half I had a rally with no
teleprompter no 30,000 feet without
dreaming no drink no bathroom break he's
just up there going he's like an animal
up there and it fuels him and then you
meanwhile you're looking at Biden and
you're like this how's this even gonna
work out his teeth are literally falling
out and he can see these four people's
names wrong did they want to win or
don't they think that is the question
like they don't want to win with someone
they can't control
[Applause]